So what I want to ask you is maybe you could help to clarify the process of detoxification
in relation to the right machine.
So that's kind of my question is how those two work together to do what they do.
And I would like to ask to that, as David and I talk, when we were listening to Michelle talk
about the clocky animal, you know, we were understanding like sometimes in some people
would say they could hold a clocky animal in their body for six minutes and then Michelle
would say things like, well, that's good at me, but it circulated in this way in your
in your body.
And then we sort of understanding a little bit more about like how things, you know, are
then eliminated.
And so just in general with the detoxifying with David, you know, with what the rights
is doing as well as with what the pharmaceuticals are doing, what is his body being detoxified?
Okay.
So detoxification takes place in every single cell.
So what's going on inside the cell is enzymatic processes and enzymes are made by different
genes.
So that's where we want to look at genetic defects that people might have because they
can have restrictions on intracellular detoxification pathways if they don't make enough duperoxide
discotaser for they don't make enough catalysts or they don't make enough glutathione or
nerf two or keep one.
So those are all the intracellular detoxification pathways.
And they don't make those.
There are certain herbs and different nutraceuticals that can help push those pathways.
So that's why you would take different nutrients and many of those nutrients are found in good
foods.
That's why, you know, you eat a lot of change your diet to eat prepared foods and McDonald's
and things like that.
They're eating good whole foods and good vegetables because they have those nutrients that will
help support and push those pathways.
So the detoxification that takes place in certain cells depends on what the thing that it is
that you're detoxifying, but many of those things are, are, are, are catalyzed in a certain
way that they're made a toxic.
No, for instance, superoxide ion is canalyzed by superoxide discotase to turn it into, add
a H2 group up to it and you end up with hydrogen peroxide that that is canalyzed further
by canelase and, and glutathione to water that you that excrete, but that is excreted.
So some, some intracellular toxins are excreted then through your kidneys via, so it's picked up
in the extracellular space through your live system carried to the blood and it excreted
through the kidneys.
Other chemicals like pesticides and heavy metals and such are keylated and excreted through
your liver into your colon, and that's why it's so, or that you're not constipated because
constipation can lead to reabsorption of those toxins.
Yeah, okay.
So the, the detox pathways are complicated in a sense, but if you just think of it, we got
to get things out of the cell, it goes out of the cell into the space between the cells that
you need a good healthy lymphatic system to drain that area, that's where exercise comes
in because the lymphatic system doesn't have a heart that's pushing it, it's only moving
through the live system through action of contraction of the muscles.
So you know, getting some exercise contracting the muscles, even if you're sitting in a chair
doing isometric exercises, getting contraction of the muscles helps move the limb, that's
where do we like rebounded, one of those little trampolines can be beneficial.
So you're getting it through the lymph to either to the kidneys to be excreted or to the
liver to be excreted into the bowel, and that's where sodas can be helpful too because
then you're excreted extra cellular matrix fluid through the pores of your skin, so you're
bypassing the liver and you're bypassing the kidneys, so it takes some pressure off the
kidneys in the liver.
So the benefit of doing confianabas is it just helps support the liver detoxification, so it
helps the liver dope.
Yeah.
So does that help answer that question?
Yeah, it does, absolutely.
And how does the life machine, how does that fit into this scenario?
The life machine doesn't specifically detoxify, but the life machine is, so depends on what
program you're doing.
So if we're running cancer programs, we're helping the body kill cancer cells, so in that sense,
it is a detoxification, you could say, we're getting rid of cancer cells, and there are
lived programs out there that can help stimulate lymph flow, but it's not going to stimulate lymph
flow like doing rebonded or something like that.
It's just going to be the, it's the frequencies.
So that is the life machine, understand, is using frequency medicine.
So everything in your body is frequency, so if you can stimulate the frequency of the liver,
you're going to help the liver work better.
So those cells are going to work better, and that's going to support the detox pathways
that way.
So in every single person's program, there's liver programming, because when you're killing,
when you're killing cancer, you have to support detoxification.
So I put in everybody's program, no liver frequencies because we want to support that.
So your overnight program is supporting detoxification, but it's supporting it by number one, killing
cancer, number two, helping stimulate the liver and its own frequency, so the liver works
better.
So we're using frequency medicine with the rife, we're using chemistry with like a nutrient
like milk thistle that would help the liver or pond one that would help the pond one pathway
or DERF-2, that would help the DERF-2 pathway where we're eating really good foods is chemistry
to the cells to help support those pathways.
The rife is using frequencies so that using other tools like exercise and rebonded is helping
stimulate levatic flow, and then the sound is helping you use the skin as a detoxification
pathway.
Okay.
Yeah, that's very good, and if we were recently googling some of YouTube's on the rebounder,
we don't have one, but we want to get action on one, because also, since David had that
cardiac experience, we were not certain how much or how little he could even say do
want a rebonder, so we've just begun to explore that tool, because it does look like it's
a great way, like you said, to do the whole lymphatic tool that you might consider are those
vibration plates, and you have a picture of them in your three ring binder.
In the diet part of the back of the diet part, there's information on the rebounder, and
other helps with detox pathways, and one of them is a vibration plate.
So those vibration plates that you stand on, or the ones that you sit and just put your
feet on, vibration, ventilation into your feet helps stimulate a little microscopic bustle
contraction, and that helps with levatic detoxification as well.
That's a great chick, we missed that, but we'll look at the binder as soon as the call
is over.
Yeah, that's great.
Thank you.
Yeah, I definitely missed that part of it, but we'll check that out for sure.